the US House of Representatives has
voted to impeach president Donald Trump
on two charges stemming from his alleged
attempt to pressure you Kane Ukraine
into investigating his political rival
Joe Biden
now both votes fell along party lines
almost all Democrats voting for the
charges and Republicans voting against
them but this doesn't mean that the
president will be removed from office
the process now moves to the Senate
where he's likely to be acquitted by its
Republican majority after hours of
debating the first article of
impeachment for abuse of power past
facts on this vote the yeas are 232 nays
are 197 present is 1 article 1 is
adopted on just minutes later the second
article for obstruction of Congress went
as planned for the Democrats on this
vote the yeas are 229 the nays are 198
present is one article two is adopted
hundreds of kilometers away at a rally
in Michigan President Trump
reacted to his impeachment with today's
illegal unconstitutional and partisan
impeachment they do not think Democrats
and they are do nothing all they want to
do is focus on this what they could be
doing are declaring their deep hatred
and disdain for the American voter this
lawless partisan impeachment is a
political suicide march for the Democrat
Party have you seen my polls of the last
four wait back in Washington Democratic
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi accused the
Republicans of being purely partisan she
threatened to delay the impeachment
trial until she could be sure it would
be handled fairly in the Senate
we have legislation approved by the
Rules Committee that will enable us to
decide how we will send over the
articles of impeachment we cannot name
managers until we see what the process
is on the Senate side and I would hope
that that will be soon so far we haven't
seen anything that looks fair to us so
hopefully it will be fair and when we
see what that is
we'll send out a net marriage with
voting concluded in the House of
Representatives and Donald Trump
becoming only the third u.s. president
to be impeached Americans now face the
next stage in the process the Senate
trial that's due to begin in January but
Democrats face an uphill battle
considering the Senate is
republican-controlled and they need a
two-thirds majority to remove President
Trump from office for now the Capitol is
about to begin a brief period of calm
over the holiday season as members of
the Congress and Senate spend time in
their homes across this starkly divided
country well join now by boris foreman
political science professor at Bard
College here in Berlin nice to see you
again Boris good morning to you the
impeachment now moves to the Senate when
is it going to get there at both sides
say they want a speedy trial and can you
walk us through what happens down the
process
oh there's sort of a transmission now
with some from the house becoming
managers of the case and moving it on
and presenting the case to the to the
Senate and then there's some some
equivocal statements that we've heard
about how it will then move on the
question is whether the Republicans will
allow any witnesses the Democrats are
insisting on additional witnesses and so
there might be a bit more of a drawn-out
process but I think what both parties
want to avoid is they clash with the
with the presidential elections in
November
okay so how long could the process take
though you know how much time are we
looking at in in the Senate well I think
that there's hope that it could be done
early in the year in the spring so that
during the primaries it will be over and
done with but there's also a an
incentive a small incentive for the
Republicans to draw it out a little bit
longer
because what the impeachment trial does
is to bog down the Senators and if
Warren and Sanders are still in the race
they will not be able to be on the
campaign trail okay now is there a
chance it's a Democrat sped in the
Senate will pass Republicans of course
have the majority there well it's as
everybody says it's highly unlikely
twenty Republicans would have to move to
the other side and given what we've seen
not just yesterday but over the last
course of the years there's a deeply
polarized political system it's very
unlikely for that to happen yeah and so
it remains to be seen but as long as
public opinion doesn't shift on this and
it hasn't this is probably not gonna
happen okay then why are Democrats
pursuing this course the presidents
described described as self-destructive
why are they going down this road well I
think the argument here is that the
founders of the Constitution the
founding fathers of the US have decided
that there are certain mechanisms in
place or have to be in place if
democracy is going to be protected and
if there is someone who puts their
private interests above the general
interest then these mechanisms should
should be played out at night this is
the Democrats argument and so they're
saying we're doing this because it needs
to be done
we've been reluctant Nancy Pelosi has
insisted on this multiple times and
later as well they've been reluctant to
get this process started but then they
had to follow through okay yeah and
Nancy Pelosi back in March said there
there's no grounds for impeachment she
didn't want to go down this road what
what changed for the Democrats well I
think having looked at the evidence
after that was what for them made a
difference the other thing is obviously
the polarization not just between the
parties but within the parties there's
been a strong constituency within the
Democratic Party that's been arguing for
impeachment and so she had pressure from
both both sides basically okay how do
you see the impeachment process playing
out in the elections
Trump won the former Democratic
strongholds in Michigan and Pennsylvania
how is this process going to go down in
those key swing states in the next
election
it seems like the positions are very
polarized again it doesn't seem like
this will change I don't know exactly
what's going to happen in those swing
states there is a reason why Trump was
elected and why they went from
Democratic strongholds to Republican
backers
I don't know however either whether what
Trump has been doing in office and the
kinds of reforms that he's been trying
to to get started really have affected
those voters in a popular or in a
popular and helpful way so it remains to
be seen
okay Boris Foreman thanks so much for
coming in give you insights this morning
from Bard College here in Berlin thanks
very much